Alright, good evening.
Good evening. Howdy to, yay, howdy.
That was different. Now, welcome to, uh,
Wednesday night at Henderson Hills.
Our equipping nights we call 'em.
And, uh, our goal is to fulfill
what our mission statement says, to equip one another,
to love Jesus and live sin.
So part of that is these classes
that we do regularly throughout the semesters.
So, as you probably know, there's some classes going on
outside of this one.
One is actually enabling somebody to get seminary credit
for a class if you wanted to do that.
That's, uh, going on in one of these rooms out here
through Midwestern Seminary.
So, uh, it's called The Story of Everything.
Jared Wilson teaches that it's really encouraging, really a,
a good study and men's women's
bible studies going on as well.
But, uh, what we're doing with this one in here is
calling it digging deeper.
And so the idea is to take
what topic was preached about on Sunday, whether that's me
or someone else preaching that to come.
Then in here again, just try to recap through what that
theological topic was, and then dig deeper into it.
Talk about some of the, some of the things we couldn't get
to on Sunday, some of the deeper nuances,
and maybe even some of the, the, uh, debates
that go on about that topic.
Some things that you might not be aware of,
things you might be aware of.
All of that we wanna do what we can to help equip you
with the theological, uh, studies that you need
to grow in your faith.
Because again, we talked about this Sunday,
the idea is not just to grow in our mental knowledge.
The, the idea is to grow in our knowledge of the God,
of the universe who's come to us to save us.
And that should be life giving and, uh, joy inducing.
So that's why we study theology.
We want to know who God is better so
that we can grow in him more effectively
and follow his mission for us, uh, more faithfully.
So what, what I wanna start with tonight,
before we get into all that, is, uh, a time of prayer.
As you know, we've done this the last week plus to
devote ourselves to prayer more, to care more.
Tomorrow at noon, right in this room,
we're gonna have a time of prayer that if you can be here
for that, it'd be a sweet time, I'm sure, to just meet
with the Lord, be still
before him, worship him, grow in our knowledge
of his word a little bit there.
But also just follow his spirit
and how he wants us to pray,
what he's already praying for us.
So Thursday's at noon, we're gonna start that rhythm
for the foreseeable future.
Love to have you that. But we want to also
infuse more prayer into our daily regular gatherings,
weekly gatherings, just to say, Lord, we need you.
And we can't do this without you.
Uh, so tonight we're gonna do that just
for a little bit to start with.
Do that probably every Wednesday night similarly,
but, uh, just to calm our spirits.
So just if you would bow your heads, close your eyes.
There's nothing super spiritual about doing that.
Of course, we typically do that in churches.
But just the idea is to calm
and quiet your spirit before the Lord
and realize that, uh, all the stuff that's happened today,
all the things that you're thinking about, all the worries
that you can lay all of that at his feet right now
and just ask him for his unique
presence with you right now.
Ask him for eyes to see,
even with your heart, eyes, to see what you want,
what he wants you to see tonight from his word,
from, uh, conversations.
What does he want you to see? Ask him for it.
I just confess to him right now that, uh,
as we'll talk about here in a moment, that you have not
desired him as much as you know, you shouldn't.
You should have, uh, all of us confess that God,
we, we don't long for you very well.
Confess that to him and receive his love in
that, in spite of that.
And just ask him now to lead you in the way everlasting in
Psalm 39 says, his eternal, true right
way of living, of thinking.
Well, we thank you for the time tonight.
You've given us, we don't take it for granted,
that we get to do this freely here.
And, uh, we have, have the facility to have
what we have tonight with kids and students
and other classes happening
and joyful sound choir, practicing,
and, uh, just the opportunities we have to do this.
God, we don't take that lightly, that we have the word
in our language, that we have people to encourage us
with it and teach us and talk to us and challenge us.
We have books in our language that teach us, show us truths.
Thank you, God. So may we
see you tonight a little better,
a little differently In Jesus' name.
Amen. So one
of the things I want to do, we want to do every week is,
is give you some resources just for follow up for things
that you might not have known existed, books,
articles, if we can.
But, uh, so there'll be usually a stack of books right here
of some sort that you may or may not be able to read,
but, uh, from where you are.
But, uh, but try to talk through, uh, I've struck,
lemme just be clear, I have trouble reading these myself.
So actual books of these, the, especially this top one.
Um, but if you're looking for further study
to dig into the topics that we're talking about,
you'll have some, some help here.
These are general systematic theologies, meaning
they take these concepts of, of who God is
and what sin is.
And, and they, they try to systematize
that topic with what God's word holistically teaches.
And so they do, uh, that of course.
And it takes a long, a lot of pages to get there.
And so these books are thick.
Uh, most systematic theologies are thick.
But, but these are a couple of the really good ones.
These bottom two, uh, bird and Erickson are especially good.
This top one is really, really hard to read. Uh, for me.
It's, it's really deep and rich. But, but, uh, he, bath Inc.
Is his name is, um, is one of the best on the subject
that we're talking about tonight about Revelation,
God's general revelation, special revelation.
So, again, you don't have to buy these, you don't have,
but I've just given you ideas,
given you some resources for that.
But here's, here's what I want to kinda start with,
is we kicked off the series on Sunday.
We had the jar, we put the rock in it.
Our first big rock, of course is revelation.
But, but as we think about this whole series,
when you think about first things first,
and these heavy theological concepts we're gonna talk
about over the next couple months,
Uh, For some of you, these are new infor,
this is all new information.
And so it might feel like it's way up here
and you're trying to swim too deep
and all this, just, just look for what God's gonna show you,
uh, from Sunday, which we'll try to, try to keep it
not simplistic, but, but more simple, right?
To understand, catch something.
But then even on these evenings,
just look for what God's shown.
That's why we prayed that at the beginning.
Look for what God wants to show you. Have his eyes.
Uh, maybe it's just one thing,
how you can apply that and love him better.
But others of you might feel like, man, this is all old hat,
like you're coming in here with,
with almost like stump the pastor questions.
You know what the, the topic is, right?
And, and so let's just be clear, let's,
that's not the goal tonight, right?
You don't, uh, the goal is information expert, uh,
for transformation.
But it, it might seem like some
of this stuff is too basic for you.
'cause you've studied, you've done great, okay?
And that you already know.
But the question is, do you really do, do I really
understand these things?
Has it taken root in my life and born good fruit?
Any of these topics, all these topics, has it,
has it really born good fruit?
Do I rejoice over these truths?
Like when we hear about God's self revelation, is
that something that causes us to rejoice?
Or do we just merely think about kind
of the academic study of it?
If if it doesn't lead us to that,
then maybe we don't know it as well as we thought we did.
I mean, 'cause Romans talks about
how God's love is poured into our hearts,
and that leads us to rejoice at these things,
not to be defensive or,
or not to be like, apathetic about these truths either.
Like we shouldn't just forget it.
I don't need, I'm not a theologian, actually,
all of us are, right?
And just dismiss this stuff.
No, we have to think like, I, I should care,
but we shouldn't be combative about any of this either
because this is not then fruit God would produce of worship
and of love for others.
So that's the goal is as we study these theological concepts
to get to that, and now we're gonna have
to put the big rocks in first.
Remember the, the, the illustration is we can't focus on the
secondary and third level things first
because then we crowd out the big rocks that we need
to put in first that are the essentials of our faith.
So that's what we're gonna get to.
The first seven of these are the big rocks.
And keep filling up that jar from there.
Because again, as Jude says, this is the faith once
for all delivered to the saints the faith.
That's a, a definitive article, right?
It's the, like, you watch those, um,
the introductions at football games when they flash the guys
on the screen and they say where they're from,
some high school or some college, right?
What, what's the one, uh,
Michigan versus the team down South?
Gray Buckeyes, right?
The Ohio State University, they say, right,
the faith, the God of the universe, not just one of many.
The and so the faith we're talking about is the thing
that Jude says the first things, this is the most important,
the common salvation that Ephesians four talks about.
The one faith, one Lord, one.
That's what we're trying to get to here.
There's differences of opinion
on all of these kinds of things.
But what we're saying with these is
that these are the essentials
that make us distinctly Christian.
That there's gonna be very little wiggle room
on these essentials, right?
There'll be some differences of application maybe or thing.
But if we don't believe that God has revealed himself
to us in these ways, then what are we doing here?
And, and who are we worshiping?
And we'll see some of these other things we go forward
with the trinity and with God the son,
and, and what is salvation?
And we'll explain all of that.
And how do we view humans
and how do we view the last things, uh, the essential parts
of that, not the debates, we'll get into that, but,
but the essential parts of Jesus is coming back to judge.
We can't deny that and still be called Christian.
You see, that's what we're talking about,
these big rocks that we'll get to.
Now again, we're not gonna say
everything about all of these.
Uh, we're gonna try to dig deeper into it in these Wednesday
nights, but again, we can't get to everything.
But that's why I wanted to make this tonight.
And, and each one of us as we go forward in the next few
weeks, a lot more focused on the q and a.
'cause we can sit up here and we can kind of assume what,
what you kind of wanna know the questions
that might be asked, and we'll give some,
some additional information of course, then Sundays.
But, but there's also like, Hey,
what are the questions you would need
answered about these things?
And we'll try to answer 'em. We can't have all the answers.
We're not, uh, omniscient that God is, we're not.
But we'll try to answer as we'll.
Have a panel of elders up here every week, try
to answer from God's word.
Help you understand what that means. So that's the goal.
So be thinking as you're thinking about
what I'm talking about tonight,
what we talked about Sunday, what are some questions?
We'll try to leave enough time for that.
Uh, pretty good chunk of time for
that actually each week to get to that.
Okay? So all that, uh, is the preface
before we get to the concept of revelation.
Now, it's not the last book of your Bible.
The revelation of John is the last book, uh,
that we call Revelation, or some people put an S on that.
It's actually not an s it's the revelation, uh, of John.
But it, it's merely when you, we don't use that word a lot,
but revealed God revealed something to John
about the future.
So we have God having revealed himself.
So we call it the revelation.
And we start with this, like I said, Sunday,
because if we start with the doctrine of God, well,
the doctrine of revelation is
how we know anything about God.
So we, we start here, other people flip that, okay?
Each of these books does that differently.
But we decided, okay, revelation first to know who God is.
And so we saw that in a couple ways.
Remember first was general revelation.
So we got into Psalm 19, if you remember that
David wrote this general revelation.
Uh, we talked about God's natural revelation of himself.
This, this idea of looking around at creation
and seeing things about God
that he has built into the fabric of nature of our bodies,
of our selves.
And it said things like declaring the glory of God.
The sky proclaims shows his creative handwork each day, uh,
burps out the glory of God, right?
That belch is the word in, uh, verse two,
each night reveals, declares knowledge about God.
Here's one quote I didn't use, Sonny Matthew Henry said,
the continual success of the day
and night, meaning it never stops, right?
The continual success of the day
and night is sufficient to declare God's power in goodness
that this thing just keeps going.
Cyclical pattern, day, night, day, night, day night.
It's enough to prove and declare God's power and goodness.
Verse three talked about the nature declaring God's glory.
It's all audible everywhere the words go out like the suns
heat covering the whole earth.
And so you think about, okay, how does it tell us about God?
Well, uh, this theologian named Theodore of Cyrus,
back in the four hundreds, he said, like,
when you see a great painting, you're,
you're in awe of the painting.
But you're also, your mind goes to like,
I wonder who painted it.
Right? You see how that he, he's saying, a an awesome
painting makes you think about the master
artist who painted it.
When we look at creation, we're like, wow, I wonder
where this came from.
You might say much more to be sure.
He says, does the sight of creation lead the viewers
to the creator just looking at this, right?
We can't be help. It can't help
but be stunned at how great God really is.
And so that's intended to humble us. We're not God. He is.
It's all about the greatness of God,
not the significance of man.
God made man small, the universe big
to say something about himself.
It's not about us. We shouldn't think it is.
We're small in the end compared to Him. He is God.
Were not be humble before that.
So then we talked about the doctrine of general revelation.
How people universally the heavens declare
it's audible to the, like, the sun's raised to the end.
And we went into Romans one to defend that.
That's the argument of why it, uh, is true,
of why we believe Romans ones,
or why we, we generally, revelation makes
everyone have no excuse.
Gen Romans one says that, that those
who have received,
or those who will are receiving God's wrath,
have the truth, but suppress it
through their unrighteousness.
So they are aware.
There's an awareness of the truth,
that God has plainly shown what he can,
what we can know about him for all times.
And what He's made eternal power, divinity,
clearly perceived.
That's why people are without excuse. 'cause.
'cause we know enough to condemn us.
We suppress the truth by our unrighteousness.
They'd own known God, but did not honor him. Thank him.
Their minds were darkened, became futile.
They've not had the gospel.
They're not aware of his, uh, wrath
and righteousness, yet they've
rejected the general revelation.
Now, we'll talk later about how people would push back on
that and say, well, that's not fair.
How, how can that be fair?
Because God didn't even give him a
chance to know the gospel.
We'll, we'll talk about that a little bit.
That's a question I know people have. But that's general.
We're, we're rejecting creation and what we see about God.
But chapter two shows us,
even in our humanity, we reject God.
His law is in a sense written on our hearts.
So there's a measure of the question people ask about
evolution is why is there morality?
That, that's a hard question to answer.
Why is there morality? There's no sense.
You should be defeating everything else, right?
That's the natural course of that.
It's because God's law is written on our hearts.
Everyone has a general, even really tiny suppressed sense
of God's law written on our hearts.
So we reject that as well.
Now, one of the questions about general revelation is, okay,
those of us who believe in God, we read it back into
creation, that we can't know this stuff about God just
because we look at creation, we are knowing God
and then reading back into it.
No, because it's objectively present.
Erickson, he said, God has given us an objective, valid,
rational revelation of himself in nature.
He also adds history
and human personality that God shows himself.
Even through history. God shows himself even through us,
regardless of whether anyone actually observes it,
understands it, and believes it,
even though it may well have been disturbed by the fall,
it's nonetheless present.
So when we look around,
we know the world is not the way it should be.
Everybody acknowledges that.
You can talk to somebody who had claimed
to be an atheist on a plane.
You can ask 'em, Hey, is everything right in the world?
Is everything the way it should be?
No, they would agree with you.
Now, their reasoning would be different of why education
or government or whatever, right?
Greed. And we would just say, well, yeah, I agree with you.
It's just all called sin. That's why this thing's broken.
But even in that brokenness, there's still evidence
that you can see God in creation.
He's designed it that way so he can be known in some form.
It's like the image of God in us.
Whenever we are image bearers of God, we are tainted by sin.
It's, it's disturbed by sin.
But it doesn't mean we still don't reflect the image
of God in some way.
Not fully, not perfectly.
But you can see how it does actually still show up similar
here in creation.
Now chapter three. So that's Genesis, uh, Romans one,
Romans two, chapter three
then indicates the solution is not just becoming more aware
of God, the solution is the gospel, those spectacles
of faith that Calvin said.
So then we went from general revelation
into special revelation that God showed himself to us
through his word.
And we get into a lot of things about how that developed.
And if you have questions about that,
we can probably talk through that.
But, but it was necessary for that to happen
because we can know enough about God to condemn us,
but we can't know enough about God to save us from creation.
We can't grasp enough from nature
and history to truly know God.
We needed him to uniquely supernaturally speak to us
and tell us about himself.
Tell us how we can be saved through
specific events like Exodus, resurrection
of Christ, prophets.
Apostles spoke his word,
but primarily what we're talking about in special revelation
is what's been in, in scripture related, the,
the recording of God's word.
What we have now as the 66 books called the Bible.
All of this points to who Jesus is, the Savior, the Messiah,
Jesus himself did that.
The road to Emmaus. After he resurrected, he's walking down
with these two disciples
who didn't know it was Jesus at the time.
He'd hidden himself from them.
But he's walking along acting
as if he knows nothing about what's happened.
And he says, what's been going on?
And they tell him, don't you hear?
Didn't you hear about this?
Jesus, we thought he was the one and he died.
But it seems that the people say he is resurrected
and Jesus is walking with them.
And what he says as he opens the scriptures
is he shows them how Moses
and the prophets all point to him.
So Jesus himself takes what we know as the Old Testament,
which was their scriptures.
And he says, look, all of this points directly
to me as the Messiah.
And he showed it to him and then
he disappeared and all that.
But that's the, the purpose
of the special revelation is not just
to give us more information about God, it's
to give us the way to salvation through Christ.
Now, how did he do it? Remember how he did it?
He did it through people. He did it through, uh, people
who were, as second Peter one says, spoke from God.
People spoke from God
as they were carried along by the Holy Spirit.
Uh, even Peter himself saw Paul's words as scripture.
This is second Peter three, as he does in all these letters,
when he speaks in them of these matters,
there's some in them which are hard to understand,
which the ignorant, unstable twist to their own destruction
as they do the other scriptures.
So Peter's looking at Paul's writing in his contemporary
time, and he says, that guy's writing scripture right now,
which I, I love, first of all, just a side note,
I love Peter saying about Paul.
He's like, there are some things in them that are hard
to understand, right?
You ever read Romans?
He's like, whoa, man, that is, that is hard.
I, I have to sit on that for a while.
And Peter's looking at that same thing.
He's like, yeah, I agree with you. That's hard.
So just and be encouraged.
But Peter was looking around at
what God was doing in the moment.
And he saw this as scripture,
but it wasn't, again, a, it wasn't a person
coming up with this stuff.
Paul just was a gifted writer.
What we call it was God speaking through them.
Super intending every word.
What we call that is verbal plenary inspiration, that God
inspired, breathed out his word.
Some people would say that what that means is
that God just basically robotically dictated every word
that we have here.
And, and there was no measure of involvement by the person.
They were just like an empty container.
And God was just making them write these things.
That's not what we actually believe
about the way it happened.
Again, it does mean that God ordained every word
to be there, but he used their context,
he used their personalities.
That's why they're not all the same.
They don't all sound the same
because Peter is different than Paul.
And, and they have different context.
Luke and Matthew read the gospels.
They're all looking at the same thing,
but they're looking at it from all these different angles,
and they're able to explain it
to a certain group of people differently.
And then this person catches it from this guy over here
and they can understand it.
It's all though still inspired
that God was super intending every word,
even the transmission of it.
Which there is books
and books written about how the transmission, uh,
Dan Lee part, we've got this on our website.
Dan Lepar taught two semesters on the development of
what we know as the scriptures.
It's a hugely deep study.
It's awesome to watch how God even kept
what the original, what we call autographs
that Paul was writing down
or his scribe was writing down that original document,
how that has been sustained through even to
what we now have in a wholly different language,
that we can trust what was written even back then.
That God superintendent, every word of that,
we can trust it even today.
So scripture gives us the way of salvation, tells us
who he is, how he he is.
Its purpose is to point us to Christ.
Because Christ then was the
personal revelation of God.
A lot of people will classify those two things together,
that they say the revelation of Christ was a class
of special revelation.
Okay, I can get your, that this guy does.
I would say though, others would say, a,
the revelation of Christ, God,
the Son showing up is at a whole nother level
of God revealing himself.
Then just, we have this God's word.
Yes, cherish it, eat it, hunger for it.
But the fact that God showed up in person,
I think that's a third category.
That's his personal revelation of who he is
and his salvation through faith in Christ.
And that was to save us. And so that's the gospel.
That's why we, we talk a lot about that.
Now, I wanna talk through a, a, a few questions.
Then I'm gonna have Aaron come up here
and he's gonna help talk through this, uh,
with us and do some q and a.
What do we do with this idea of general revelation?
Because okay, we, we can't know enough to be saved by it.
What do we then, what's the benefit of studying
what we might call natural theology or general revelation?
Well, first of all, you should just be stunned.
I should just be stunned by the glory of God in creation.
It should cause us to worship.
Like I, I get to drive down 33rd East in the mornings.
So this sky over here just explodes
some mornings with an incredibly beautiful sunrise.
I mean, fire reds and all kinds of stuff. Beautiful.
I can't help but look at that. Wow, God, you are amazing.
That's the way it should be first.
But then it also, and this, there's a lot more we could say,
but this idea of general revelation gives us a starting
point with unbelievers.
If you launch in with the gospel to some people,
they're gonna write you off like you're a
cult follower and crazy.
But if you can find a way to relate about just creation,
like if we look for those connections with people,
there's actually a way in to the gospel eventually
with somebody about general
revelation starting that conversation.
So look for that. You can find ways, there's plenty
of resources we can point you to about that.
But this idea of general is also the compelling reason.
One of the compelling reasons why we live sent,
why we talk about mission so much.
Why we talk about taking the gospel to people.
'cause the only way to be saved, Romans 10, the only way
to be saved is to believe in God's offer of grace.
Jesus Christ, faith in him.
That's the only way Romans 10 says, how can they believe?
Unless they hear, how can they hear?
Unless someone preaches, how can they preach
unless someone sends them?
So at the end of every service, we say we are sent,
Christ has sent us to do this,
to proclaim the way of salvation in Christ.
Because they can't believe just by looking
around at creation, they can't believe enough to be saved.
As genuine as they want to be about, as, as faithful
as they are to whatever they're doing.
It has to be the gospel.
So that's why we're compelled to go.
God's the one who's gonna sort it out,
who is saved and who's not.
That's not our job. Our job is to take the gospel
to scatter the seed, and then he sorts it out from there.
That's what we have the responsibility to do.
That leads to another question.
What happens to those who don't ever hear the gospel?
It's a common question. It's a good question.
'cause it means you're thinking what happens
to those who've never heard about Jesus?
The common question in our, or the common answer in our day,
because we go back, I said this earlier, we go back
to the fairness of God in our minds.
Well, that's not fair, God, if, if you're gonna condemn them
to hell and they didn't have a chance
to hear, how fair is that?
How good are you? Are you really good?
God, that's, that seems a little too much.
We have to be very careful to sit in judgment over God.
We, we have to be very careful that we don't do that.
Even, even with a good design.
And listen, the the answer that way is a, it's
because we care about those people, right?
It's because we love, we don't want anybody to go to hell.
And so we're like, oh, surely that can't be true.
Well, you just take that little phrase to its logical end,
you're gonna get in a lot of trouble.
Surely that can't be true, right? Oof.
You could say that about a lot of things.
And all of a sudden you're getting down some really,
really dangerous pathways.
So what happens to those who've never heard about Jesus?
I found this article, um, I kind
of read through it a little bit.
I think it's a good summary of
the way we could think about it.
I wanna add some things to it as well.
But we've said this
before, that all, all people are accountable to God.
Whether they're not, they've heard about him.
Romans one, we saw that very clearly.
The problem is we're sinful.
We reject knowledge of God, we rebel against him.
Um, in reality, it's not
that some people have not heard about God, the problem is
that they have rejected what they have heard
and what is readily seen in nature.
So nobody's quote unquote innocent before God.
So Deuteronomy four says,
if from there you seek the Lord your God, you'll find him.
If you look for 'em with all
your heart and with all your soul.
Okay, well, everyone who truly seeks
after God will find him.
If you truly wanna know God, God will make himself known.
The problem though, which, okay, so that leads to, well,
yeah, that guy's generally seeking, fully seeking God.
He just doesn't know who he is. Okay?
Romans three, the problem is
that there's no one who understands.
No one who seeks, God genuinely seeks.
So, so there's the, the parallel between those two things
that, yeah, okay, well, if you seek God, you'll find him.
But nobody seeks God. It's our sinful nature.
We'll get to that in a couple weeks.
We worship a God of our own creation,
even though we can see enough about God in our own hearts.
You know, we, we can't debate the fairness of God
because people are responsible to God for
what he's already revealed to them.
They reject that knowledge, therefore, God is just,
and so we, we then trace,
and this is one thing, I'm, I'm
still trying to work through my head.
I'm still talking it out.
So if, if you have answers to help me,
this would be great later.
But when you think about, uh,
a mythical tribe in the middle of the jungle somewhere,
and you look at them and like they've never heard,
they've never had a chance to hear all of that.
How could God send those people
away from his presence forever?
Well, you think about at some level,
I'm fleshing this out at some level.
Somebody in their family line, 400 generations back,
heard about Yahweh, heard about Jesus,
potentially they rejected that
and then eventually migrated down to this
village in the middle of the jungle.
And when you think about in the Bible,
old Testament especially, you see the curses of the Father
on the generations after.
And then you see the blessings of,
of the Father on the generations after as well.
Each person is culpable, meaning they're guilty
before the Lord on their own.
Nobody's gonna stand before God for me
or for you or for anyone else.
We stand before God on our own guilty,
innocent, all of that.
It's by the grace of God.
We're innocent, but, but we stand by ourselves.
But there is a measure. When you look at Ezekiel.
There's a, a passage talking about the watchman on the wall.
Whenever there's a charge to that watchman
to blow the trumpet,
whenever they see the enemy coming, he has a responsibility
for himself, but also for those people in the city.
So he sees the army coming, he blows the trumpet,
the army comes in, destroys everyone.
The way it says it is that their blood is not on his hands
because he blew the trumpet.
He warned them and they did nothing about it.
But then it says that if he doesn't blow the trumpet,
the enemy comes in, destroys the people,
their blood is on his hands.
Now they all, I mean this, I don't mean to laugh about this,
they all still got destroyed, but,
but his, his culpability in that he's a little bit guilty
on behalf as well.
So there's a measure there of this group
of people doesn't know because somebody back here also
is guilty of not passing it on.
'cause you trace every family line back to Noah's family
before that, back to Adam and Eve, right?
So you can trace it all back
to some level at some place along the way.
Somebody said, Nope, we're done. And they moved on.
And then everybody after them never heard they're guilty.
But God has some, some blood on that guy's hands
that family's hands as well.
Now, I don't know if that's right or not,
but I'm, so I'm trying to think
through some implications of that.
But again, that question, what happens to those never heard?
What should it do for us?
It should compel us to go to live sin.
Now, we're, we don't believe that
somebody would be saved if we tell them,
but they're not saved because we'd never told 'em that
that devalues the sovereignty of God,
his election, all those things.
We'll get to that in a few weeks.
I'm not in control of someone else's salvation, right?
That's not in any way true.
But what it should mean is that we should be compelled to go
because God is worthy of the glory
of everyone hearing about that.
So if we assume, now here, here's the implication.
If we assume that those who've never heard
are granted mercy by God,
then it would be unloving for us
to go tell them about who Jesus is.
We would want to do everything we could to try
to keep the gospel from them so they wouldn't hear,
so then they could die and go to heaven.
You see the implication of that, right?
That's a universalism, that's a, it's completely counter
to the Bible's teaching.
If people are never hearing the gospel,
that means they're automatically saved,
then we should never, never tell anyone
and keep them from hearing about it.
So you can see how that's a logical fallacy
that if they never heard, then God's so,
so the compelling thing here is again,
what does God's word say?
Go make disciples of all nations.
Take the gospel to these people.
If they can't hear, they can't believe.
If they can't believe they're not saved.
So you can follow the logical end of that,
but that means we should be compelled what privilege we have
to be a part of what God's doing
to see people saved around the world.
Okay? Don't push that too far
with the wash one of the wall thing.
But I think it's helped me kind
of understand a little bit there.
Okay, Aaron, come on up here. Let's do some q and a.
I've talked enough. So we'll have, uh,
I think we have some mics around.
Do we, I don't know if we did get those out. Not sure.
Just stand up and talk really loud if you would.
And we can try to answer.
We again, are not, uh, like the word.
We are fallible, we are limited,
but we can try to help answer some questions.
And especially Aaron
can't, 'cause he's a lot smarter than me.
So questions you would have,
let's just go ahead and get started on that.
Uh, raise your hand. Stand up. Go for it. Right over here.
Cheer go. Gary. Yeah,
John, just uh, follow off on the, on the last conversation
because I, in trying
to formulate something in my mind terms,
our granddaughter asked this kind of question of Christmas.
So it's a relevant question for
Yeah. Generations
as well.
Uh, where does, how does Romans two fall into this
and talking about if you have not, if you not have the law
and you do the things of the law,
then you'll be redeemed.
Is that part of the answer as well?
It's, uh, versus 12,
I think on that.
In other words, if you have not, it's like what Paul said,
if the law, the law exposed send
to us without the law, we did not send.
Right? So I'm, I'm just trying
to formulate my own mind too. Same thing,
You're, yeah. So
the question is Romans two 12
and following talks about, for all of sin, for all
who have sinned without the law,
will also perish without the law.
All who have sinned under the law will be judged by the law.
For, it's not to hear is the law who are righteous for God.
But the doers of law will be justified for when gentiles
who do not have the law by nature, do what the law requires.
They are a law to themselves,
even though they do not have the law.
They show that the work of the law is written on their
hearts, while their conscience also bears witness.
And their conflicting thoughts accuse
or even excuse them on that day when according to my gospel,
God judges the secrets of men by Christ Jesus.
Now, he never says anything about those gentiles
being saved by that.
He just says that it shows the,
the law is written on our hearts 'cause Yeah.
That let's think that mythical tribe in the middle of jungle
still do good things for one another.
They still care for babies.
They, they, you know, there's evidence of that,
that God has written that law in their hearts. You think?
Yeah, I agree with that.
And Romans two is an extension of Romans one.
Paul is making an argument that people
instinctively know that there is a God
because of creation, the things that he has made.
And they know that there is a God
because of the conscience that he's given them.
They all have, we all have this instinct
that we know there is a God because of what we see.
And we know instinctively right
and wrong, God's law
written on our conscience, our hearts.
And so we have no excuse.
Creation condemns us and conscience condemns us.
So Paul is making a case whether you have the law as a Jew
or you don't have the law as a gentile,
you still have a conscience that condemns you and
therefore he is making a case for Romans three that all
of sin and fallen short of the glory of God.
Yeah. If that makes sense. Good.
Okay. What else? Good question, Gary.
If I could go back to, uh, just
what John was saying earlier, totally agree with, with
what he was saying about someone who's never heard.
We have to be careful there
because God is
not obligated to save anyone.
We, we, we throw that out there
and we think that he's not fair
or he's not just, if he doesn't save anyone,
he's not obligated to save anyone.
To be fair would, would be to let us go
to hell for our sin.
Uh, so we have to remember that we are not condemned
because we haven't heard of Christ or salvation.
We're condemned because we're sinful. Our sin condemns us.
That's why we are ju to be judged.
And if God wants to save somebody in the boonies
in the middle of the woods, he can do that.
The sovereignty of God can reach that person,
but they still instinctively know there is a God
'cause of creation and conscience
and that still condemns them.
Uh, when they suppress the truth. They know.
Paul says, I'm sorry, we had a question. Yeah. Bob,
You good?
Yeah. This is, I guess along the same line,
but a little different also, uh, the question is, uh, people
who have the gospel, they don't understand
that young children are
what happens with them.
I mean yeah, guess everybody's a sinner from birth. Yeah.
So they're too, but,
and you can tell them the gospel that they wouldn't be
Able to put Yeah.
Yeah. That's a great question, Bob.
That's a, that's a natural follow up to that very question
where the question is, okay, what about someone who can't
comprehend the gospel, whether that's
because of, uh, disability
or age, you know, like a, an infant.
Um, we've got a family in our church dealing
with some really heavy, uh, in utero
things with a baby that, that may not make it.
And so the question is, what happens to that baby?
The sinful nature?
God send that 2-year-old
'cause they can't comprehend the, the special needs adult.
Like where do we fall on the mercy of God there?
Do you have initial answer there?
Yeah, I don't, I don't know the answer to that.
Um, again, we're born into sin. We're born condemned.
Uh, we have to trust the sovereignty of God on that one.
And, you know, there's people who hear the gospel
and don't understand it of all ages.
And, and so we have to trust the Lord knows what he's doing.
He has chosen those who, uh,
he wanted to redeem.
And, uh, you know, we do our part in sharing the gospel.
But I, I don't, I i don't claim to know the answer
to, to that one.
That's, that is one of the, that's one
of the questions they ask you in seminary ethics class.
Like that's a fun one. Now, I would say Go ahead. Yeah.
That we got lot of hands went up.
Yeah. I would say just in light of that, this is a
deli delicate because we just said
we can't say, uh, surely God wouldn't do
that in this case over here regarding those
who haven't believed, right?
This one we could say a similar thing, right?
Well, surely God wouldn't do that.
But when you think about
God's mercy and love, that's, that's
where I'm gonna fall on in that situation.
Again, we don't actually know.
Scripture doesn't say there's some debate about age
of accountability in scripture.
That's a, that's a muddy water to walk in.
I think we, we gotta be careful with that.
That's why we preach the gospel to babies.
We preach the gospel to two year olds.
We preach the gospel to everyone, special needs adults.
We, we preach the gospel to everyone.
And here's the thing, we don't know what's going on
inside there either.
That's why we do fall in the mercy and sovereignty of God.
'cause I don't know how that six day old baby,
we, we think they can't comprehend.
They don't understand. Do we really know that?
See, God, this is, this is where the bigness
of God gets into this a little bit more.
I, I want to believe and,
and probably could make a case that God would save those
because he has a special heart for orphans, for widows.
There's a, there's a uniqueness in his mind towards certain
groups of people.
Again, he's not loving someone
more than others, but you see what I mean?
Like, he's, he's got an eye towards the refugee,
towards the, the, the outcast, right?
He's got an eye towards certain.
So I think, again, I'm not gonna definitively say,
but, but I do want to rest in that mercy and,
and love of God for that
and trust that he's doing something for that baby, for
that specialized adult, for the gospel when I preach the
gospel to them, that they can hear
and understand if God, if that's God's,
but that's between him and them.
That's his deal. I trust him with that.
My responsibility is to love them
and proclaim the gospel to them.
Good question though. Those are, those are two
instant common questions that come from this.
For sure. Yeah. There was somebody back here had
Some other hands. Yeah.
Here you go. I got a mic.
We got a, we got a mic coming right here. That'll be Mr.
Steve Murdoch. Its looking very fresh tonight.
Steve, I wonder, did you something change this week?
You know, he slept in late, he slept in late today. Oh,
If I'm Not, he retired, by the way.
So if I'm, if I'm not mistaken, we have the example
of David's child when he died.
Yeah. That David was positive that he would
see his child again.
He says, I, he will not come to me.
I will go to him, I I'll correct to be with him,
is kind of how he phrases that.
Correct. Yeah. That, that's commonly used.
And I don't want to disagree.
Some people would say that's Sheol the place of the dead,
meaning he's not gonna come back to life,
but eventually I'm gonna die like he did.
That's so that's part of why we'd say, well,
it sounds like David believes he's gonna be with Yahweh.
Correct. But we can't definitively say a hundred
percent that that's what he meant.
Because there can be some debate about the just death in
general that he wasn't gonna come back
to life even though he was praying.
Right? Correct. He was praying for him to come back
to life and he wasn't.
Correct. He didn't.
So I'm gonna go eventually die like he did.
He won't come back to life like me.
So, but it's a great point, yes. That's often used.
Yeah. And again, we have to be careful.
We can't assume anything with the Lord, uh,
or impose that he has to save these babies.
Otherwise, you step into
what John was talking about a minute ago with universalism,
you, why not just, and this is gonna sound terrible,
but why not just kill all of our babies
and then they'll go to heaven?
Uh, that, that's a dangerous theology to get into.
Uh, so yeah, we just don't know.
We have to trust the sovereignty of God on those
who pass away in infancy.
We just don't know. We just don't know.
Back here. This would go along with, uh,
like the tribes who have never heard
the gospel had that opportunity.
In Romans chapter nine where it talks about,
it's talking about the, the sovereignty of God in verses
around 2324, it refers
to the potter has control over the clay,
and it refers to, uh, the vessels who are prepared
for destruct destruction versus the vessels who were,
uh, prepared for grace.
Some translations say destined
for destruction rather than prepared for.
So I don't know if this would be a passage
that would play into that, uh, particular discussion or not.
Yeah, you're gonna get into
that in a few weeks, aren't you?
That or is that me? Salvation?
I'm salvation. You're Salvation. Yeah. Okay.
Yeah, that's a good point. Uh, Gil, there are,
again, we're, we're not condemned
because we don't hear of Christ.
We're condemned because of our sin.
We're sin, we're, we're born into sin.
We're sinful from birth, conceived in sin, David says.
And so there are some that are destined for destruction,
uh, just as Romans nine says.
Yeah,
heavy topics.
And, and I, I think, feel free to ask another question,
but that conversation, what he just said,
can get really, really cold, fast and harsh.
And, and it's true to say God's,
God's sovereign over salvation.
Not everyone's going to be saved,
and God has planned all of everything.
And so we, we have to define that,
but we shouldn't be like flippant about that
and rejoice in any way about that.
Because like Aaron said
before, really none of us deserve to be saved.
Like It's by grace at all that he saves anybody.
And so if we know the gospel
and we have seen God in his word, in salvation,
his Holy Spirit planted inside of us as the down payment
for eternity, man, we should just be dumbfounded
and stunned, first of all,
that you were born in a time
and often a place that you could hear and believe
and a free place that you could worship and respond.
None of us chose that. Right?
So be stunned
and be broken 'cause of sin.
Sin is the reason wrath exists.
So be struck by that hate sin
and worship Christ
because of his grace to you if you believe.
Yeah. What else?
Got a few more minutes.
Elizabeth's got one right here.
S So it almost feels like,
it's almost like we have to wrestle with a little bit
of survivor's guilt.
Hmm. You know,
like when great tragedies happen
and people walk away from the building that collapse
and they don't understand why them Yeah.
And not others. That's kind
of, I don't know.
Is that the right it, I it shouldn't feel guilty,
but it feels guilty.
That's a good question.
And yeah, I would, I would be careful using the word guilt,
but I get the point and it feels like that at times.
So I think we,
we should let that feeling again, first
spur us towards worship.
Uh, Like gratitude. Yeah.
Just this sense of wonder
that God would do this.
He would come to us, tell us about himself, save us.
Like what? So yes,
there should be this wonder and gratitude.
And, and that's what, just as a side note, when we do
what we do on Sundays up here, when you read your Bible
and you're in personal worship with the Lord, you know,
we are not just trying to create emotional experiences.
It's not the goal we're trying
to put on a great performance.
Everybody get into it
and shoot t-shirt cannons
around, make everybody excited, right?
Like, that's not what the goal is to say,
look at how great our God is.
Look at how gracious he is. Look at how loving he is.
Look at what he's done. And we've seen it.
We've witnessed it. We sing that song, right?
We've witnessed it and he's done these amazing things
and we should just be stunned.
But I think I can feel now,
maybe more than I ever have when you ask that question, what
that feels like to hurt that some don't know.
Many don't know that.
And, and I, I think it should, should break us a little bit
not to accuse God.
Because there's all kinds of scriptures that say, here,
God, you're not fair.
How could you do this? We don't ever want to accuse God,
sit in judgment over God, But
it should just break us.
Like for our neighbors, for the lost tribe in the middle
of nowhere, for the
prominent atheist who's out there trying
to defeat Christianity for the, the good guy down the street
who doesn't love Jesus, but he loves everybody else.
Like it should break us for that
and compel us towards, I don't know who's gonna be,
I don't know who God has ordained
and not, I, I don't know that my job,
my job is to care and love
and sacrifice like Jesus did for me,
for everyone else around me.
And to proclaim this truth, the gospel,
because I know when he says scatter the seed,
there's gonna be good soil out there.
Somebody's gonna believe. And the grief
that we will feel the rest of our days
until Jesus comes back is
that some people will turn away from that,
or some people won't ever hear that,
And we should feel that you're right.
But there's coming a day then where I, I think part
of the fear, this is, um, I'll let you talk.
I talk a lot, but, um, we, part of the fear,
and I think we've gotten this image in our head
that we're gonna look, we're gonna be in heaven
and somehow looking down
and watching people suffer who we know
and love in life and, and we're gonna see it happen.
I just don't think that's gonna be that way
where we're gonna have this measure of grief in heaven
because of all this,
because of what we're talking about right now.
I just don't think that's true
because there's no tears in heaven.
There's no grief. All that's been washed away.
That's a tough one for people to wrap their minds around.
Is, is how God could do that.
But his ways are higher than our ways.
His thoughts are higher than our thoughts.
And, and the beauty
of it is we should wrestle with this stuff.
If, if we're sitting here,
this is the whole reason we're doing this series.
If we're sitting here and we're talking about these things
and we're just kinda like, yeah, whatever God's good,
we're gonna do it and we're not wrestling with this kind
of stuff, then you're gonna get an a question asked
of you at some point in your life
or a situation gonna come up in your life at some point.
And all this is gonna finally collapse on you
and you've never wrestled with it before.
That's gonna be problematic in that moment.
So we need to be wrestling with these things.
It's a great question to ask.
It's a great heart processing to do, to consider where,
man, where do I land on this?
How does, how does God's words and
and really let it force you back into his word
to cherish it, to study it, to glean what you can
and eat his word.
Uh, because we should be wrestling with these things and,
and we shouldn't be afraid of having hard conversations
and talking about hard things and hear this last thing.
Um, God's a big boy.
He can handle it when we bring this stuff to him
and say, God, I don't get this one.
God I don't know this. Oh boy, this is hard.
This was hard to get. I don't know God. He can handle that.
He can handle our doubts or questions,
and he wants you to come to him in those things.
So don't hide that.
Don't run away from that half the questions
with people asked through that talk.
Read these kind of books.
I mean, there's people who've thought about this for
40 years of their life
and they've tried to write how they can formulate that.
But in the end, there's gonna be things we just don't
understand about who God is.
And that's good because he's God and we're not.
But don't run away from the questions either.
So you got anything else?
I love your analogy of surviving a, a burning building
and not knowing why.
Um, all I can say is we, we
trust the Lord with all our heart
and lean not on our own understanding.
We have to trust the sovereignty of God.
He has his purposes for those who died
and for those who live.
And I just have to say, thank you, Lord, be grateful.
Figure out why I'm still alive.
What's my pur what's his purpose for me?
And, uh, maybe there's somebody I'm supposed to be sharing
with, but, um, that's a tough one.
You just have, we just have to trust the Lord has his
purposes and be grateful that we are one of his.
So that's a great, great analogy.
So we have, uh, worship leader
development happening in here in about 12 minutes.
And so we'll be around,
there's a few other elders here as well.
Um, if you have any other questions, look at these books,
those kind of things, whatever you wanna do.
Um, but within the next 12 minutes, like you don't have
to go home, but you can't stay here kind of thing, right?
So just go out to the lobby if you want to continue
to have conversations, they're, they're not gonna run off,
they're not gonna, they're not gonna kick you out
or anything, but just, you know, that's,
that's what's happening next in here, just so you know.
But, but I honestly did not know
this whole how this was gonna go.
Now lemme just be clear.
There's gonna be some weeks, this'll be a lot.
I thought this week was gonna be
the easiest of all the weeks.
Okay. We started pretty good tonight, didn't we?
Like, okay, so, um, the next,
these will be hard as we go into it.
Attributes of God, the Trinity, God, the Son,
and lemme just again remind you,
we don't know everything about this.
We are fall and fallible.
We're trying to process, we're learning along with you.
Um, so let's show grace to each other in this Let's learn
how to disagree at times.
Let's walk through some things. But,
but our hope is to point you to who I,
who God is over the next few weeks
especially, and just grow in that.
Learn who he is. Uh,
but there'll be times I would guess we'll be up here
and be like, I don't know.
And it's okay to answer. I don't know.
It's, it's a measure of humility in that we should, right?
If we don't know the answer, don't try to act like you do.
So let's say, all right, I'll help.
I'll look for the answer, I'll help find that for you.
Let's talk later. That kind of stuff.
Uh, but that's the exciting thing for me
after tonight, is to see how this is gonna go.
And, and we're gonna work hard to, to be ready and prepared
and as best we can, but also just realize
that we're not gonna know it all.
And that's a good thing. 'cause God is bigger than us.
So God, thank you so much for tonight.
Thank you for these men
and women who wanna dig a little deeper
and, uh, have these hard conversations.
Kind of think through the implications of these truths.
Like just that you've revealed yourself in creation to us,
in your word through Christ.
Um, God, there's a lot of questions
that we don't know the answer to.
And so in that we come to you,
we need you Holy Spirit, we need your wisdom
that you would meet us in our time of need,
in our lack.
He would show up and you would teach us Jesus.
You said the Holy Spirit's gonna illuminate.
So we prayed that that would be true.
As we study your words, we hunger for it, thirst for it.
I prayed that you would, you would give each one of these
a, a measure of humility
before you give me a measure of humility
before you, that you are God of the universe,
but also this measure of confidence that you are imminent,
you are near, you're with us.
And Lord, if, if you are for us, who can be against us,
your ways are so much higher, God, we will see
that many times over the next few weeks.
There's so much about you.
We will never understand anything we try to do
to explain you only reduces you in some way.
But Lord, we pray that in, in our weakness,
you would show yourself strong in our
lack of understanding.
You would show yourself wise in our lack of ability
to answer questions people would ask.
Show yourself to be the answer to people.
Give us faith, faith when we don't all always understand
everything we have faith in you.
So, Lord, thank you. Thank you for the great questions,
the good thinking and deep thoughts tonight.
And I trust you'll lead us as we go.
Uh, give us strength and prepare us for Sunday as well
as we take on the next topic about your attributes, what
that means, who you are that you've revealed to us.
Thank you, God.
Give yourself even more glory as we know you better
in Jesus authority we pray.
Amen. Amen. Love you church. Thank you. We are sent.